[Music]
you know cadaver dissection is the
traditional way of learning human
anatomy for students it's a quite an
experience
but for school it could be very
difficult or expensive to maintain so we
learned the majority of anatomy class
taught they do not have cadaver
dissection lab maybe those reasons or
depending on where you are cadaver may
not be easily available so to address
this we developed with the dr. Brown in
Stanford virtual dissection table so we
call this an optimal table
so with this anatomage table student can
experience the dissection without human
cadaver and that table form is important
and since its touch interactive just
like the way they do you ties actually
in the lab or furthermore just a way a
surgeon operates patient you can
naturally interact with a you a table
our digital body is one-to-one life-size
so this is exactly the way students
would see the real Anatomy I'm going to
do some demonstration as you can see I
use my finger to interact with my
tea-stall body I'm going to do some cut
I can cut any way I want to so I cut
right here then it's going to show
inside and I can change my cut to see
different part
maybe I can cut there see the brain and
I can change my cut you can see some
internal organs so we call this this
slicer mode
okay I'm going to do another cut right
there it shares a lot of internal
structures so if I want to see the
backside I can flip and see from behind
like this so if these images are
uncomfortable to you or disturbing to
you that means we did the right job so
our doctor said these are eye candies so
instead of just a picturing the body I'd
like to be more clinically meaningful
dissection what I'm going to do is I'm
going to peel off all the skins muscles
and bones just to see a few internal
organs right here let's say I'm gonna
cut liver right here okay so let's say
I'm interested in looking at heart I'm
gonna do some surgery here just like I'm
cuttin some veins arteries oops
you don't want to here it's in real
surgery
but fortunately our digital man has undo
okay
all right let me zoom in I'm gonna make
cut right there and then you know you
can see the inside of heart you can see
atrium and ventricles how blood flows to
artery and veins just like this students
can isolate anybody and dissect any way
you want to it doesn't have to be always
dissection since it's digital we can do
reverse dissection so let me show you
I'm gonna start with a skeletal
structure and I can add a few infinite
organs yep maybe I can add quickly this
way and I can build muscles gradually
just like that we can see tendons and
muscles which I could build my muscle
this fast and this is another way to
learn Anatomy another thing I can show
you is more often than not doctor get to
meet patient in x-ray form so anatomage
table shows exactly how Anatomy will
appear in x-ray and you can also
interact with the U x-ray and also if
you want you can compare with how
Anatomy would appear in x-ray to you so
when you are done just bring back the
body and then it's ready for another
session look like our table or so can
transform gender - it's a female now so
this is an optimal table thank you
[Applause]
[Music]